Ginny is with us in North Carolina hi
Jenny welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
wow I'm such huge fans of both of you
and Rachel thank you so much for ready
your contentment journal I love it
absolutely so I have a question
regarding a family member that you all
would term you would call him a left
winger dinger and I kind of saw more on
the libertarian views of things and I
only see the family member about three
times a year and he is much smarter than
me and I'm the type of person where when
we're in a conversation I do about 95
percent listening and only about 5%
talking so just to get your tips on how
to talk to him more intelligently next
time on this topic because I know it
will come up again and he's up in arms
well he's always up in arms about
something but he's up in arms right now
about the like inequality of wealth
distribution and how the rich keep
getting richer and how is someone that's
down and out to come up and out if they
don't have a car if you're on parole
they've never had a job they're in this
such-and-such circumstance and the only
intelligent thing I feel like I brought
the conversation Dave was I remember
years ago you did an analogy of you
versus Brad Paisley so I did it
me versus Taylor Swift of it's not
unfair cuz he kept saying a term it's
unfair it's not unfair that Taylor Swift
makes more money than I do cuz she's a
better performer she's beautiful she's
great at what she does so do you guys
have any tips because this conversation
will come up again and I just would like
to to put forth more intelligence you
know words to the conversation that's
fun yeah um you know what I I seldom
enter into these arguments anymore
except here on the air because I don't
you know in our families I've not found
them to be fruitful because I don't
think there's enough words in the right
to change this guy's mind and I I don't
think he's really taking a poll I think
he's just running his mouth and he
doesn't really care about what anybody
else thinks nor is he planning to change
his opinion so I don't really think you
can change his opinion I've got family
members that are politically on the
other extreme from where I am and I'm
pretty extreme on the other side and I
just love them enough to love them who
for who they are and I really don't
think I'm going to change them so I just
encourage you to sit there for a while
and be comfortable in that first and
foremost but I mean the analogy you laid
out is is that wealth inequality is fair
is accurate it's it would be unfair for
everyone to have the same level of
wealth because everyone does not have
the same work ethic for someone to work
one hour a week and someone to work 40
hours a week and then to have the same
money it's called communism it's not
wealth equality that's called communism
and it's completely unfair for someone
that works one hour a week to have the
same income as someone who works 40
hours a week and it's completely unfair
if someone has a greater talent at
something and the marketplace is willing
to pay them more than someone who does
someone who can't play a guitar versus
someone who can play guitar getting paid
to play the guitar you know you don't
know how I don't I've never strung a
single note on a guitar at least on
purpose that made sense together and so
for me to get paid for that would be
completely unfair and that was the Brad
Paisley comparison Brad's a friend and
he's a world-class performer world-class
musician world-class guy in general but
he shouldn't get paid for being a
world-class guy he gets paid for singing
and I'm on talk radio because I can't
sing and so he gets paid more than I do
and that's okay and I'm okay with that
you know so that I can't throw a
football like Peyton Manning that that's
kind of the discussion we had but I
don't think that those arguments are
gonna change this guy because this guy's
and he's living in an echo chamber where
all he hears is the same stuff all the
time from his little group yeah and I
think that I mean some of his points
Ginny I think that it's fair to say
though like to bring humanity
into all of this like do some people
have harder stories than others have
others dealt with things in their life
you know that are more tough than others
yeah a hundred percent like everyone's
life looks different but the belief I
think is different and that you you know
I believe that no matter who you are
again some people it's a more difficult
situation than others but no matter who
you are as long as you not lost hope
there you can have a different outcome
with your life you don't have to keep
repeating the same mistakes in your
family stories that's what we see a lot
of you know you can look at you can get
into poverty you can get into all these
you know social subjects where there are
some really really tough problems and
really sad situations but if you just
believe that that's how it's always
going to be then you've lost hope in
that point and I think that you know dad
and I both would say no matter who you
are in the world you have to have hope
and when that hope is there that you can
create a better life I mean everything
that Chris Hogan talks about with you
know the with millionaires that you know
80% of them eight out of ten are
first-generation rich I mean like so you
just hear these we hear the incredible
stories of people that have dug
themselves out of really tough
situations and some of them were high
school dropouts that were parolees
that's what I'm saying that's a really
hard story yeah and I just think both
sides can be polarizing in the sense
where you just take the humanity out of
everything but you can bring it down and
say yeah I hear you
uncle or whoever you are like yeah I
mean there are some really really sad
tough situations but I still believe in
the American Dream and I think you know
if you can do it but I don't even know
if you need to engage in it just like
dad was saying earlier okay no the thing
is too the question is when you're
thinking if you were really going to and
try to intellectually debate with
someone on that situation is the problem
is not that we don't agree that those
are both situations I mean poverty is a
real situation people who have never had
a chance yet are born into a zip code
that that's a real what you're saying is
there's a humanity that yeah that's a
real situation we don't disagree on the
other side of the coin that there's a
situation we disagree about the solution
right yeah the solution what's your
solution to help the little man
a government program tax the rich so
there's a government program so you want
to help the little man with a program
that's as efficient as the DMV well see
that's where we don't agree on the
solution
there's been no government program
that have proven to help poverty
zero-zero government programs have
alleviated poverty none and yet the the
the the capitalistic system in America
today is where the little man has had
the best chance in the history of the
human race to move up the social ladder
to move up the income ladder no other
system in the history of the human race
has given the little man as much of a
chance as that so it's not the problem
that we're not in agreement about it's
the solution to the problem that we're
not in agreement about but again I think
you're just they could just barking at a
dog I mean it's just not just a bunch of
dogs barked at each other it's not gonna
he's in an echo chamber he's not gonna
hear anything